[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg
dans cette nouvelle édition d' europe
hebdo c'est parti pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans cette
émission direction la finlande depuis le
1er janvier dernier le pays
expérimentent le revenu universel 2000
personnes tirées au sort ont chaque mois
un versement de 560 euros
une mesure qui suscite le débat dans
toute l'europe mais d'abord l'actualité
le parlement britannique a autorisé
theresa may a déclenché le break site
la première ministre avait à l'origine
décidé de notifier cette semaine cette
décision à l'union européenne c'était
sans compter sur nicolas star john la
première ministre écossaise qui a
déclaré vouloir lancer un référendum
d'indépendance de son pays
retour sur les faits avec aurélie
d'aphatie
[Musique]
emma est vieux et et j'estime qu'il est
important que les causes soit en mesure
de décider de son avenir
la première ministre écossaise l'a ainsi
annoncé en début de semaine
l'ecosse souhaite organiser un nouveau
référendum pour sortir du royaume uni en
les écossais avaient voté à 55% contre
l'indépendance mais peut-être l'horizon
du bric site va-t-il changer la donne
dans ce pays très pro européens
c'est en tout cas le pari que fait le
parti nationaliste à l'horizon 2019
les écossais pourraient donc ne plus
faire partie du royaume uni et le
royaume uni ne sera plus européen car
les britanniques quitteront l'union
européenne en mars 2019 au plus tard
depuis le vote de juin dernier le break
site est en marche souhaitée par la
population il est désormais approuvée
par le parlement
theresa may peut donc activer l'article
50 du traité de lisbonne qui lance deux
ans de négociations de sortie de l'union
à bruxelles
les autorités européennes se préparent
les lignes directrices des négociations
sont prêtes
une fois adopté par les dirigeants des
états membres place aux pourparlers
[Musique]
le bric site va-t-il signer la fin de
l'union jack du royaume uni pour en
débattre je reçois philippe juvin
bonjour vous êtes député membre du
groupe ppe et donc des républicains au
sein de ce parlement bienvenue à vous en
face de vous guillaume balas bonjour
vous êtes vous membre du groupe
socialiste et démocrate
enfin jean marie cavada vous êtes au
sein du groupe adl c'est à dire le
groupe centriste
messieurs est ce que le risque et on le
voit avec le bric site c'est que à terme
ce soit carrément le royaume uni convoi
se dissoudre un philippe juvin c'est un
des risques évidemment c'est à dire que
les apprentis sorciers de l'année
dernière du bric site david cameron
avait raconté de belles histoires dont
david cameron absolument 1 et quelques
autres quand même avait raconté de
belles histoires en disant que de
nouveaux en étant seulement nous allions
nous les britanniques reconquérir de la
souveraineté
le résultat est là premièrement avec une
soixantaine de millions d'habitants il
faut pas imaginer qu'il puisse peser
dans un monde mondialisé deuxièmement
ils veulent tellement partir que ça fait
un an qu'ils gagnent du temps pour ne
pas partir ça montre qui a probablement
un loup dans la sphère et troisièmement
comme on commence à faire les comptes
on s'aperçoit que loin de récupérer de
l'argent puisque c'était un des
arguments majeurs et très populiste et
populaire de la campagne
eh bien il va falloir que les
britanniques payent entre 40 à 60
milliards d'euros 106 milliards d'euros
ce qui montre que les choses sont plus
complexes
nous on voit bien que les britanniques
n'ont pas hésité à jouer avec le feu
avec la pile ou face et la nouvelle
étape c'est que les causes pourraient
partir et l'irlande et l'irlande partir
cameron finalement aura déposé son pays
si jamais on en arrive à de telles
extrémités guillaume mallet c'est ce que
le risque ce qui est pas aussi un effet
domino dans la volonté de déclaration
d'indépendance de certaines régions où l
inverse ça risque de les calmer mais en
tout cas ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que souvent les nationalistes
disent que l'europe bride les nations on
peut se demander si au contraire
l'existence de l'union européenne ne
protège pas les unités nationales et je
me demande si par exemple l'espagne
sortait aujourd'hui de l'union
européenne ou d'autres pays si on
pourrait survivre
je crois qu'en fait les moments de
mondialisation tels qu'on les a vécues
ces trente dernières années
un même les gens à retrouver à essayer
de retrouver une forme souveraineté et
le problème c'est que quand on accuse
l'europe d'enlever faussement cette
souveraineté
on croit la redonner à la nation alors
qu'en fait les gens vont aller chercher
des identités qui sont encore
infranational on le voit avec les
régions ça peut être le communautarisme
ça peut être d'autre chose donc bien au
contraire il ya une articulation
évidente aujourd'hui entre l'union
européenne et vidé nationale et penser
que l'europe est l'ennemi des nations et
bien c'est sortir de l'europe et faire
exploser son pays c'est ce qui risque
d'arriver moi je crois vraiment on en
est même à un tel point que un des
responsables du pays de galles a
commencé à évoquer l'idée de sortir le
pays de galles alors je pense pas que
c'est majoritaire au pays de galles mais
pour qu'on en soit ou égal à dire cela
on voit quand même à quel point les
logiques de divergences sont là et le
risque jean marie cavada c'est que là
aussi on ait un effet domino que ces
identités régionales comme une hauteur
fasse exploser encore plus alors
l'identité européenne qui n'existe pas
mais a minima l'identité peut-être
nationale d'abord moi j'en ai assez que
ceux qui ont travaillé pendant 60 ans
pour un projet européen c'est à dire le
bien des peuples qui a enrichi la
prospérité d'une part même si tout est
loin d'être parfait
c'est normal l'europe n'est pas absente
de la critique et on doit pouvoir
l'observer la critiquer mais j'en ai
assez que les pro européens soit acculé
toujours à justifier ou à se défendre de
quelque chose qui a été le meilleur
projet depuis probablement dix siècles
en europe c'est-à-dire un fin de la
guerre de prospérité 3 les libertés
défendu quatre la libre circulation et
quelques autres choses notamment la
défense des consommateurs qui peu tendu
il est dans son pull yeah man remis en
cause aujourd'hui justement oui vous
avez raison récurrence intra européennes
oui pourquoi les teams mis en cause eh
bien il est remis en cause par des
politicards de bas étage qui ne sont que
des hâbleurs de quartier georges qui
s'ils agissent au parlement européen ces
gens sont des détracteurs et des
destructeurs parce que le 2000
représente quand même aujourd'hui on l'a
vu sur le référendum donc du bric site
une majorité oui bien entendu parce que
les peuples dans ses pales métier c'est
pas le métier de conduire le destin
d'une nation c'est d'écouter ce qu'on
leur dit ils ont été charmés par ces
hâbleurs dont je vous parle qui se sont
appuyés sur des difficultés du royaume
uni interne au royaume uni comme c'est
le cas en france des difficultés
internes à la france pour essayer de
dire c'est pas de notre faute
c'est la faute de l'europe mais c'est
moi j'arrive au pouvoir vous allez voir
tout va changer le mans change a fait
partie du processus de destruction de la
grande bretagne
les vingt-sept vont devoir se réunir
pour déterminer les guidelines donc les
lignes directrices pour le mandat de
négociation dans le cadre du brics it s
qui à part un risque là aussi qui est
des fractures entre l'est et l'ouest
guillaume balas g20 d'abord le prix de
briques site c'est un fait il sert à
rien de se lamenter ils ont décidé
qu'ils l'assument
maintenant il faut aussi qu'on en tire
nous les conséquences c'est-à-dire que
si les britanniques ont décidé de sortir
c'est qu'ils avaient des choses à
reprocher à l'europe même si nous
considérons beaucoup ici que en réalité
il ya beaucoup de de théâtre dans cette
affaire et on leur a présenté une fausse
copie mais les citoyens nous disent à
l'europe ça marche pas bien
donc moi je n'entends ça est ce qu'il
faut faire qui sait pas c'est aussi en
2005 en france avec le référendum et
qu'on n'a jamais il faut faire oser
inventer mathy cet inventaire en ouvrant
un nouveau modèle et c'est pour ça que
moi je suis très favorable à l'idée
d'une europe à plusieurs vitesses ce qui
est certain c'est si on ne fait rien si
on pense que partage spécialement par la
france et les autres et bien l'europe
disparaîtra donc l'europe doit lé il
faut la réformer de l'intérieur mais pas
la tuer c'est pour ça que me benoît
hamon a fait une proposition notamment
de traiter de la zone euro que je
soutiens et l'idée c'est pas comment
avec ce traité et à prendre et à laisser
il est justement à discuter mais ce qui
a manqué beaucoup et là pour le coup de
la part de la france depuis une
trentaine d'années c'est la proposition
politique la france par essence j'allais
dire et celle qui fait des propositions
politiques en europe et le problème
c'est qu'elle a été quand même
reconnaissant le 2 puis françois
mitterrand assez absente sur ces sujets
et donc il est très important
aujourd'hui de dire si nous voulons une
europe qui soit dit à plusieurs vitesses
à kser series dont plusieurs mois je
considère pas que c'était une avancée
majeure il a quand même sauvé le bidule
et et je pense que y compris la manière
dont lisbonne a répondu par exemple à la
crise de 2005 en france et au nom en
france n'a pas été la bonne manière de
faire donc maintenant il faut quand même
prendre au sérieux la question de la
démocratie en europe donc de la
démocratie de la zone euro avoir une
monnaie aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
contrebalancé démocratiquement est un
réel problème et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
ces propositions de benoît hamon
d'une assemblée en fait de la zone une
assemblée parlementaire de la zone euro
et je crois que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement faut y compris le débat en
allemagne aujourd'hui nous permettent
pour avancer sur ces sauf que pardon
mais je pense que si vous permettez
enfin si vous donnez en fait cette idée
de donner un parlement en fait à la zone
euro est ce que ça va parler à nos
concitoyens
jean marie cavada on verra on verra plus
tard sur la façon de le faire mais ce
qui est vrai qui se dégage d'ailleurs de
ces discussions c'est qu'il est temps
maintenant de passer à ce que macron que
je soutiens dans la campagne française
appellent l'europe des souverainetés
c'est à dire au fond tout ce qui est
régalien les pays qui veulent s'unir 3 4
6 8 peu importe pour mettre ensemble je
dirais la défense des européens la
sécurité à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
là un parquet fédéral un antiterroristes
européens bref ce qui est vraiment très
très important qu'un pays tout seul ne
peut pas faire que les pays librement
veille s'unir et bien il faut le
soutenir
alors il ya un autre débat qui agite la
campagne française au delà justement de
l'europe et de la représentativité des
citoyens c'est une des thématiques
portées par benoît hamon entre autres
c'est le revenu universel
la mesure en finlande est expérimenté
depuis le 1er janvier donc une forme de
revenu de base sur 2000 finlandais tirés
au sort reportage en finlande de flora
sauvage
[Musique]
nous sommes au nord de la finlande à 400
km du cercle polaire ce pays de cinq
millions et demi d'habitants qui conduit
% de chômage test le revenu de base
depuis le 1er janvier 2010 est une
allocation versée chaque mois sans
condition et sans obligation de chercher
un emploi pendant sept ans yuuwaa a eu
une entreprise de menuiserie et la crise
économique est passée par là
depuis il est au chômage c'est mon
ancien atelier je fabriquais des
encadrements de fenêtres en bois
mais depuis cinq ans est devenu un débat
dans les périodes d'activité les plus
fortes
j'ai employé jusqu'à 4 personnes noda m
voici un exemple de ce que je faisais ça
se fixe au dessus de gens portent à 38
ans ce père de six enfants survit grâce
au salaire de sa femme est
aide-soignante
il touche aussi une allocation parentale
de 800 euros tirés au sort comme demi
chômeurs pour expérimenter le revenu de
base du huard se brassent ans 1 60 euro
par mois pendant 2 ans ce revenu
remplace son allocation chômage mais il
continuera à le toucher même s'ils
retrouvent un emploi
une somme qui reste faible dans un pays
où le revenu moyen s'élève à 2200 euros
par personne et par mois
yes men d'or j'ai cette opportunité
d'avoir deux ans devant moi pour faire
ce que je veux et expérimenter des
choses à cannes
je n'ai rien à perdre donc je peux
prendre des risques essayez de me lancer
dans différents domaines
voir si cela fonctionne ou pas est lancé
ma petite entreprise
le sort de liu assez joué à des
kilomètres de là à helsinki
cayla l'agencé gouvernementale de
sécurité sociale en charge de
d'expérimentation veut faire de ce
revenu un levier pour le retour à
l'emploi c'est l'objectif est de voir
dans quelle mesure ce dispositif va
inciter les chômeurs à accepter un
travail plus facilement mais en tant que
fonctionnaire je vois aussi un autre
aspect ce dispositif va permettre de
réduire la bureaucratie tant du côté des
chômeurs que du côté de cayla
car dans le système actuel toutes les
quatre semaines un chômeur doit
réactualiser sa situation envoyer les
photocopies de ces feuilles de paie s'il
a un emploi à temps partiel par exemple
tout ceci représente des tonne de
paperasse pour l'administration et pour
les chômeurs c'est très frustrant mais
cette expérimentation a un coût 20
millions d'euros sur deux ans patronat
et syndicats s'opposent à la
généralisation de ce revenu universel
qu'ils estiment totalement utopiste et
trop coûteux et un final ce dispositif
coûte extrêmement cher car un revenu de
base aux montants élevés nécessite un
taux de taxation très important ce qui
n'est pas réaliste et si on baisse le
montant du revenu de base cela
reviendrait à baisser le montant des
aides aux plus pauvres ce qui n'est pas
faisable politiquement donc il n'y a
vraiment aucune solution acceptable si
ce revenu était étendue à tous les fans
en des cela conduirait à une
augmentation du déficit public de 5 % du
pib ce qui est absolument énorme
un déficit qui s'élève déjà à 70 % du
pib en finlande alors le travail sur un
refi il devient urgent de trouver de
nouvelles formes de revenus même titre
que la taxation des robots le revenu
universel devient une piste à explorer
des mousses helsinki est un think tank
de tendance libérale
ici on estime qu'il faut faire évoluer
le système actuel de protection sociale
existing savons tous que notre système
actuel de protection sociale ne peut
plus fonctionner comme avant
donc il faut prendre en compte les
évolutions du marché du travail le
revenu de base semble être une bonne
idée pour remplacer notre modèle
existant dorénavant nous devons tester
et expérimenter des choses pour trouver
des solutions pour le futur au lieu à
terme si l'essai est concluant la
finlande pourrait étendre le revenu de
base à toute sa population selon les
experts une généralisation du revenu
universel à tous les finlandais
signifierait une augmentation des impôts
de 10 à 15 milliards d'euros
[Musique]
première question philippe juvin je vous
vois tickets plus ça ne m'étonne guère
finalement est-ce que c'est pas une
solution est ce que c'est pas moins un
débat à voir à l'heure où la zone euro
en moyenne un taux de chômage de 10%
bon la question du revenu universel
d'abord tout le monde y met un peu
n'importe quoi on l'a même vu d'ailleurs
dans le débat de la primaire de la
gauche sur le fond la question qui est
posée c'est celle de la redistribution
des richesses dans une société moderne
donc que les richesses doit être
distribuée ça va de soi et la prestation
sociale de tous types servent à ça nous
nous pensons que l'idée du revenu
universel pose des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes structurants dans
l'organisation de la société au delà du
coup absolument ahurissant le projet
numéro 1 de à mons était doublé le
budget de l'état donc c'était
inimaginable jeu le vrai cela le vrai
sujet de levier de l'étape 4 milliards
d'euros ça me paraît beaucoup à toi on
était à 300 400 et gardons un pardon
recomposée non la question qui peut se
poser certains à gauche le disent
regarder si demain vous payer tout le
monde d'une certaine somme pas pardon
mais il ya des patrons qui vous diront
vous touchez déjà 400 euros 600 euros
bah votre salaire il va peut être de
1200 mhz et 2 800 parce que ça vous
suffira la valeur travail à une forme à
effet devant claude et en ciel
évidemment nous donc nous nous ce que
nous disons c'est que nous n'avons pas
le premier sou pour le payer
2 ce qu'il faut faire c'est assurer que
tous les français quand ils connaissent
des accidents de la vie importants liés
en particulier au marché du travail soit
aidé secourus et est engagée à reprendre
le travail
mais cette idée de verser de l'argent
comme ça
nous nous paraît totalement folle parce
qu'elle et déstructurantes alors
guillaume balas bien entendu vous n'êtes
pas d'accord mais non mais c'est parce
que c'est complètement caricatural
d'abord hamon a toujours proposé quelque
chose de phase et évidemment et avec une
première phase depuis le début ou alors
si vous n'avez pas écouté les débats et
c'est peut-être ça vous intéressait pas
je vais nommer des sentiments mêlés
membres et bat yam que ma mère ne pas
dénaturer les 18 25
on a changé cette deuxième phase pour
justement se généraliser aux bas
salaires dont nous aurions ce que c'est
toi une somme de rs à améliorer quand on
va là aujourd'hui
bien sûr la réalité depuis les années 70
c'est que le nombre d'heures travaillées
en occident ab c'est pourquoi il va
baisser pour plein de raisons dont la
numérisation puis la robotisation mais
aussi aujourd'hui des algorithmes 1 je
pense par exemple au blog shane qui vont
aujourd'hui détruire des emplois c'est à
dire la désintermédiation massive d'un
certain nombre d' un certain nombre de
sujets et qu'est ce qui se passe et
comment ça se traduit ça se traduit
d'une part par du chômage dans certains
pays chômage chronique ce genre
alémanique par exemple dans les pays
comme le nôtre où il ya cent mille
personnes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail chaque année ce qui n'est pas le
cas d'autres et dans d'autres pays par
du sous-emploi sous-emploi qui vous
savez du temps partiel subi etc etc et
donc partout en réalité la socialisation
des revenus du travail a commencé les
regarder le danger d'ajar tu paraissais
les gestions fait déjà leur est donc ce
qu'on est en train de dire tu n'as que
électrise on sait déjà qu'un jeu c'est à
c'est à construire nous sommes dans la
première phase aujourd'hui de la
socialisation des revenus du travail
il va falloir l'accentuer la
flexisécurité mon général
en réalité derrière se profile qu'à un
moment donné il y aura le revenu
universel jean marie cavada s'il vous
plaît il faut que nous ayons dès
maintenant en france comme toujours du
lever du soleil à son coucher son
circuit est source de contestations
politiques
c'est une bonne question que pose ce
débat avec une mauvaise réponse
la bonne question d'abord c'est quoi
mais moi je sais pour il l'avoir regardé
cette près que dans les salles de marché
à londres ou à new york par exemple
plusieurs milliers d'emplois de ce qui
était autrefois les traders de ce que
fait réel par exemple
ont été détruits parce que les
algorithmes et les machines font ça bien
plus vite et avec de moindres risques
parce que l'ensemble des informations
qu'elles qu'elles engrangent vont
prendre une décision en quelques
fractions de seconde sont certainement
un peu plus mesuré
ça c'est la question elle existe on ne
pourra pas y échapper il y à une sorte
de transformation des postes de travail
et pendant le temps de transformation il
ya des gens qui vont tomber dans le trou
qui seront au chômage sans emploi que
c'était moi mais la réponse est mauvaise
pour deux raisons la réponse est
mauvaise parce qu'en fait ce qu'il faut
trouver
c'est une sorte de sas pour accompagner
pour que les gens ne soient pas dans
l'extrême pauvreté l'emploi perdu et
l'emploi donc ça veut dire quoi personne
en fait qui vont être dans l'intention
d'y et permanente finalement absolument
mais en permanence je ne le crois pas
parce que les sociétés ont toujours
mécaniquement transformer les hommes
donc on va pas commencer à dire que tout
le monde va être au chômage de même à
terme au titre qui a des rabots
d'ailleurs en france la question est
absurde pour l'instant parce qu'il ya
pas de robot il y en a très très très
peu mais il faut aussi changer il faut
aussi changer alors arrivés notamment
malgré la question de base aussi qui me
gêne beaucoup là-dedans je ne crois pas
aux bienfaits d'une subvention qui
maintient les gens dans leur cuisine
chez eux on a dit beaucoup de bêtises
sur le travail le travail n'a servi pas
il libère mon fils est oui oui je veux
l'exprimer jusqu'au bout
c'est quelqu'un qui a une place dans la
société c'est une des variétés
entreprendre ça évidemment créé être
autonome et crée sa propre vie
évidemment ça c'est une valeur ça ne
passe pas que par le travail et parfois
le travail peut être extrêmement
aujourd'hui asservissant mais c'est très
important de le dire
justement justement que progresser vers
le revenu universel pas le faire du jour
au lendemain progresser dans leurs
universités jouent le dit c'est
inéluctable et je prends date
pendant un an on verra mais l'idée ce
n'est pas d'avoir zéro allocation
évidemment il faut d'une économie de
redistribution et elle existe un des
soucis qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est
que parfois il n'est pas intéressant
économiquement pour un certain nombre de
comptes nos concitoyens de reprendre un
travail parce que l'organisation du
système de redistribution est telle que
vous n'avez pas intérêt à travailler et
donc ce que nous ne voulons pas avec le
revenu universel c'est tombé dans
insiste
en fait il n'est plus intéressant il
n'est plus justifié de se mettre au
travail parce qu'on n'y a pas intérêt
c'est ça que nous voulons pas vous savez
avec le revenu universel le risque c'est
quoi c'est qu'on nous dise sur la vision
que les femmes à la maison il fait pas
et des travailleurs gagnent un peu parce
qu'ils ont déjà leurs revenus à
universal alors elle vrais sujets n'ont
malheureusement pas pu avoir pour tout
le temps mais on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur cette question en un mot le
robot peut-être un jour prendra ma place
il ya déjà des robots qui font le même
des articles dans les rédactions que ça
c'est effectivement jean marie cavada en
un mot une piste taxer les robots
on sait qu'ils vont arriver non non
d'abord taxer les robots en france ne
mènera pas beaucoup de revenus parce
qu'on est très insuffisant avec
l'aileron rognon vous parliez vous même
les rucks et toutes les on va pas taxer
toutes les innovations qui arrive c'est
pas là qu'il faut chercher la ressource
le sur la question des robots moi
j'entends ouhlala faut pas taxer les
robots de cet art qu'est ce qui se passe
il se passe que quand vous avez une
entreprise qui investit qu'il ya des
robots et qui augmente par exemple on
maintient sa masse salariale de son
nombre d'employés
ça c'est une aide à la production
évidemment qu'il faut pas taxer ça tout
le monde est d'accord là dessus mais
c'est toujours tout ce qu'on a dit c'est
dès notre programme en revanche quand il
va y avoir remplacement et notamment
avec le cas beaucoup dans les services
et pas simplement par rapport à la
robotisation mécanique mais y compris
par rapport aux algorithmes seulement
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure
là il dispose quand même un petit
problème c'est que en plus l'entreprise
va faire des économies par rapport aux
cotisations sociales et donc toute notre
protection sociale qui est assise
aujourd'hui sur la question de taxer le
travail en très grande partie va se
retrouver des finances et et c'est pour
ça que qu'est ce qu'on propose
on propose une là dessus on propose une
taxe se passe sur le robot lui même mais
sur la valeur ajoutée du robot une part
pour compenser en partie justement ce
qui va être la destruction de la
ressource pour la sécurité sociale
sylvain et jean marie cavada mme vraie
question qui est posée par guillaume
balas et est ce que les robots vont
provoquer du chômage de masse j'observe
aujourd'hui parce que je n'ai pas de
boule de cristal qu'en allemagne il ya
très peu de chômage il ya beaucoup de
robots oui mais bon en france il ya
beaucoup de chômage et peu de ruminer
beaucoup de pauvres première observation
il part deuxième observation
l'innovation il faut l'aider
l'accompagner il ne faut pas la taxe est
bien sûr troisième 3ème observation
plutôt que de taxes
robot moi je préférerais qu'on taxe -
les humains et là pour le coup
recréerait de la fuite enfin si on taxe
les robots et les humains il ya plus de
sécurité sociale a besoin
je voudrais d'une phrase rappeler que
monsieur balas par exemple n'aurait pas
eu ce souci
s'ils sont partis en 2007 avait accepté
de commander la tva sociale qui
permettait de financer la protection
sociale sur la consommation fait passer
des armes et non pas sur la consommation
et non pas et non pas sur la production
qui étudie la sécession du sud idriss et
la correction par des taxes et des
consommateurs que cette question va être
à reprendre dans mais à mes yeux dans
une phase d'évolution entre un mec qui
est périmé de nouveaux métiers qui
arrive pas et au milieu il va falloir de
toute façon prendre en charge cette
protection sociale merci messieurs tout
de suite c'est le checkpoint d'europe
hebdo préparé par thomas mignon cette
semaine on a passé au crible
l'idée que l'europe est à l'origine de
80% de nos textes de loi le checkpoint
est tout de suite
[Musique]
l'europe nous impose tels ces lois cette
idée a la vie dure depuis des années
relayé encore et encore par les
eurosceptiques d'extrême gauche ou
d'extrême droite
selon ces discours une majorité des lois
nationales sont imposés par l'union
européenne et un chiffre est parfois
mentionné 80% de nos lois sont décidées
à bruxelles
d'abord d'où vient cette estimation en
tout cas aucune étude ne mentionne ces
80%
pour beaucoup d'observateurs elle
viendrait de jacques delors en 1988
alors qu'il est président de la
commission y déclare or l'europe ce sera
en 1992 80% de la législation économique
financière et fiscale qui sera d'origine
européenne
une prévision que certains ont repris
comme une affirmation mais quelle est
aujourd'hui la proportion de loi issu de
l'union qui on prend le cas de la france
l'une des rares études quantitatives
montre que sur près de 35000 textes de
lois en vigueur en 2008 un peu moins de
10000 venait de l'union européenne
c'est moins de 30% plus récemment une
étude a mené une analyse année par année
sa conclusion est catégorique le mythe
des 80% est pris à rebours dans 80% des
cas les lois françaises sont adoptées en
marge de toutes contraintes européennes
directe autrement dit la proportion des
lois issues de l'union serait ici de 20%
et dans le reste de l'europe
là aussi les calculs arrive plus ou
moins à la même conclusion au
royaume-uni 15% au danemark 14 % en
autriche 10 % et laitues dont
l'estimation est la plus haute concerne
l'allemagne 39 % mais on a beau chercher
les lois venues de l'union ne sont
jamais majoritaire alors 80 % de nos
lois décidées à bruxelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'était le checkpoint de thomas
mignon et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci messieurs d'avoir débattu sur ces
questions bien entendu on y reviendra
sur la taxation des robots et sur le
revenu universel c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous la semaine
prochaine avec ahmed tazir à bruxelles
c'est très bonne semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]